okay here we are run over time let's ask
the pen oh here's one for you Cal
joining our panel with the will the
asian-american vote make a difference in
the 2014 election uh
I think it can yeah absolutely this is a
community that it's a recent immigrant
community a lot of them historically are
underrepresented they haven't registered
to vote this ties into a lot of the
polling stuff that I've been talking
about if they go out and register to
vote yeah absolutely look at how far the
Indian community has come just in the
last five years or so when we can what
I'm saying we never used to see Indians
in pot bobby Jindal and yeah Kaling and
I mean they used to be completely
invisible you yeah no it's true it's
it's a it's a it's a community the
others this post 1965 immigrant wave
after the Asian exclusion act and then
another post 1980s wave and it's a
community that's coming of age and I
think it's a good thing do people think
you're something else do they lick your
Puerto Rican or something uh I think
because and I yep beige but you know
brand-new people I hear this from all
the time they like the regular American
white person has no clue they just don't
get I think it depends I think it's
funny like older white folks obsess
about it younger people don't yeah and
then there are Latinos that will come up
to me and start speaking Spanish that oh
I wish I did yeah yeah bill every
election every election this fall could
be controlled by the turnout forty five
or fifty percent of people don't vote
you get five percent more turnout it
would swing every election in the
country this is for you senator would
you consider caucusing with the
Republicans if they gain control of the
Senate I have gotten that question a lot
as you can imagine my answer is always
the same I'll make that decision at the
time based upon what I think is best for
Maine right that's it what you're okay
and not America and America Maine first
Maine first
really main comes before America that's
who elected me that's pretty good that's
okay General Clark do you think the US
will ever withdraw its troops from
Germany Japan and elsewhere around the
world in other words will the empire
that we're never supposed to have end
it's not gonna end really there for the
long haul and when you used to command
all of them right you were a head of
NATO who's in NATO but you know if you
look at what's happening in Ukraine
right now with Vladimir Putin and the
tanks and the Russian equipment still
going in the fighting still going on
there despite the so called truce and
our NATO allies in Eastern Europe are
very concerned they want more US troops
back if you look at what's happening in
Asia with China's military buildup and
the pushing on the South China Sea they
want those American troops there and the
ships and the planes I think we're going
to be there for a long time yeah they
all [ __ ] on us until they're in trouble
and then I'm like big drunk-dial us you
come over at how closely but it's true
it's true they need us but then you know
it's a mutual relationship we need them
too we need their diplomatic voices we
need their economies and so forth so
this is the leverage we have and you
know we don't want to have to use that
leverage those troops are supposed to
keep the peace not fight I joined the
United States Armed Forces the idea was
we were going to prevent war not wage it
and that still should be the goal of the
United States and the United States
Armed Forces why do we have a Department
of Defense but not a Department of Peace
well we we've looked at that for a long
time we created it we created an
Institute of Peace in Washington we
study it that's the State Department and
actually the whole write the whole
government has to work together and we
are we have made progress we've come a
long way since the end of the Cold War
but when you look at what's going on as
I say with Putin today we look at the
pushing by China then you have to say
okay let's let's make sure we don't lose
what we had we've got a lot of work to
do in the next few years
with those two countries what are you
thinking about the way that Republicans
get away with talking about Putin and
Isis like Ted Cruz Isis I'd take them
out yeah it was actually that why would
they surrender to you because you were
chickenhawk with a law degree well how
are you gonna take them out that Obama's
are not already doing or or Chris
Christie said about Putin invading
Crimea said well given Who I am
he would have made a different choice
you know there's a lot of muck there's
my cuz you're fat he wouldn't have dared
there's there's a lot of posturing but
if you look at where Isis is right now
and what the administration is doing for
God's sake let's don't put US troops in
on the ground right it's a religious war
putting up a water Isis once absolutely
it's like putting gasoline on a fire
to put US troops in that fight but the
airpower can make their powers fine but
this is what just there are so many they
do the airpower themselves these
countries have Air Force is why do we
have to always be the guardians of the
galloping to where we're gonna be in and
out of the Middle East for decades
because this region is in so much
turmoil we have to push and shove and
nudge on it but we got a we got to learn
the lesson well here's there right
shouldn't we be ant govern should we be
sanctioning Saudi Arabia for funding
Isis yes
yes but we're not doing this because
this is an ally this is a state you know
when you talk about Islam actually you
should talk about Saudi Arabia about
what have is 'm which is the real
ideology of al qaeda of isis of Boca
Haram of Shabaab this is the ideology
that I have and I I think you should
understand the difference between
historical Islam and the very first Isis
state that's called Saudi Arabia 1932
they decided they will get rid of all
interpretation all the School of Law's
Hanafi Shafi'i Maliki and handily they
didn't they didn't care about those they
wanted to go directly to the source
Quran hadith literal interpretation the
way you interpreted it's the way they
interpret they see violence this is what
they see this is what they've been
exporting but we didn't do anything
about it this is a country that gave us
bin Laden this is a country that gave us
15 of the 19 hijackers of September 11
this is the country that actually is
financing over and over but we don't do
much about it because it's harder what
we do go after ordinary Muslims and
harass them this is what we do not only
that we have to also to stand up until
another country that is Egypt the
greatest thing we can do for US national
security honestly is to become energy
independent and right where the price of
the Isis
Shack is that's what this country needs
to be I mean we're going to Egyptian
president Sisi and we're treating him as
a hero when he's the guy that actually
inside of his prison is giving us the
next al Qaeda and the next the next Isis
and we don't do much about it we give
him two billion dollars a year I think
poor Americans deserve that money more
than sushi I'll tell you this I'll tell
you this here are a lot there are a lot
of bad choices in the Middle East and
we've made most of them we really have
but you know I mean we've done really
much at the right time we don't do
little at the Pentagon so 200 jihadis
after September 11th in caves today we
have fifth but wasn't in the heart of
them but the choice in Egypt to be
secular the choice in need you to be
honest is between either a Mubarak or a
CC or the Muslim Brotherhood that's what
happened is the Muslim Brotherhood a
preferable choice absolutely not
absolutely not the general are wrong
you're both wrong I'm sorry to move
beyond fair and tyrant we need to move
tyrant are the guys that gave us
Ayman Zawahiri the current leader of al
Qaeda why did they give us egypt aemon's
over here because of the torture
chambers he left that torture chamber
and guess what he had one idea
transnational jihad and we keep doing
the same for Muslim Brotherhood better
than that look at look at Tunisia
they voted out the Muslim Brotherhood
they bolted them out now
why don't you look at the big picture
but you are seeing
oh no let's not go back thank you very
much ladies and gentlemen happy
Halloween